what body part are you most proud of
I mean please
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God I really have to say I know
I've opened doors
oh thanks for coming back I always love
you you're very funny thank you I always
love you too I love your books after I
came here and I you know enjoyed your
company then I read your books
the Spanish version of the books need
the Spanish version don't be so racist
[Applause]
oh my God my God I feel like I feel like
I've been here in a long time oh no so
happy to have you here did you miss me
yes I
missed you so much I miss you a lot yes
I love you
don't be creepy
yeah it sounds very good
I'm afraid I would be kidnapped
they don't even know who you are over
there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm feeling I know I'm feeling famous
I promise you like a pilgrimage I uh so
where we also know who David Letterman
yeah okay relax now who uh
now you're a huge star down there in
Columbia right and every show every TV
show that you're on the ratings go up
correct I hope yes no that's our
research said that yeah your hips down
there now so what's so funny
I'm just being humbled you have to be
homeless
now when you do this role are you
putting on a thicker Accent on purpose
because when I ever talk to you in
person you do have a very sick I'm
jealous of my accent
she's like you
even in my in the girl that does Works
in my series what's her name Julie
Roland no that's not her name Julie
Bowen it's her name
I was tricking you I was tricking you to
see if you were
smell it then all right
beautiful what do you feel I feel um
I don't tell me you don't feel anything
Sofia Vergara sounds like she has a dick
in her mouth I hate hearing her talk
what's wrong with having a in my mouth
a topography so we have everything we of
course we we eat rice beans a delicious
soups Meats Chicken vegetables organic
everything is organic do me a favor say
say a chicken for me one more time
chicken
[Laughter]
doing the stripper four and did
something wrong and things went wrong so
he got hurt he got hurt it's dangerous
to be a stripper I thought it was just
fun and games but no
that's why I gave it up yeah
Sophia Vergara has an amazing body but
the face not so much
foreign
unlikable host in the late night I don't
see how anyone can stand to watch him
[Music]
from acting and writing to sound editing
and stunts
our Academy is more diverse than ever
before both in front of and behind the
camera resulting in a greater diversity
of Storytelling so funny and delicious
good I'm glad and if there's anything
else I want you to always want to come
here and enjoy your time so I see now
that you put an effort and you know you
have to be nice to you
you have to be nice to your dad
now what's going on with your personal
life right now because you're not are
you single I know your boy your son is
going off to college yeah he's going to
college next year this is my last year
with him I'm so like you know like
trying to be with him but he he doesn't
he hurts me a little bit now he doesn't
want to be with you what about his
friends
the same thing they don't want to see me
anymore like they don't care they're
used to me
foreign
you know that phrase you show me a hot
girl and I'll show you a guy who's sick
of her
you know that phrase maybe that's your
girlfriend because that has no
for yourself Chelsea
and our Academy never loses sight that
no matter the device or platform
television has and will always be about
great storytelling
so I I used two days worth of it but you
can still have you I think you have left
over like two or three days when you
travel
how many more you got in there
as always you look absolutely gorgeous
you look fantastic you like it yeah yes
[Applause]
you looked right down from my camera
collection this is from the Kmart 36.99
so as I put the hair black oh yeah and
now she's so hot and latty
and so you know you didn't have that
problem because you look more Mexican
than a taco that's for sure
you said you're learning you're learning
I'm learning all the things but not that
oh so you're not going to do that you're
not going to call me no yeah
yeah
it doesn't matter you don't understand
it doesn't matter yeah
do your son have like he must have
hundreds of boyfriends wanting to sleep
over right I mean my son have hundreds
of boyfriends wanted to I don't mean
boyfriends I mean boy friend male
oh
I I don't mean
um
you know what I mean right whatever yeah
listen again they're just used to me and
don't look like this when I'm in the
house you know cooking and cleaning the
toilet and you're not scrubbing the
floor yeah I don't look like this I look
like like you know yeah right
are you a superstitious person I'm Latin
what kind of question is that it's like
we're all day I'm not they like
you do all that stuff yeah
you protect yourself from the evil eye
and that sort of thing look I'm full of
evil eyes
but there are 34 lies I don't know what
yeah well you're not superstitious
though are you oh yeah no he really
don't like trying to be American now
it's very quick question it's a truth
that you're really a blonde yes I'm a
Blonde you know I must most of brunettes
want to be a blonde you're a blonde who
is a brunette I had to fake it to make
it in Hollywood
well look I'll I'll tell you what I'm
doing in New York I'm usually working
right now I'm promoting my camera line
look this is my outfit from my line for
camera do you like it do
it just wait a minute yeah you can go
you can go into Kmart somebody can go
into Kmart and buy that dress and buy
this dress these earrings everything
everything you see here you can get a
camera yeah but
for 29 no no no this one is like 49.
have you ever greased a bobcat
[Music]
it's a very easy game you know I'll
explain it to you soon but let's
announce the opponent's uh coming out
okay is it great
do you want to show everyone how you
high-five me during the commercial break
because this is enough of this I
name three things that rhyme with push
thank you
I I saw that first yeah
my name
maybe a beauty tip for a people you
slather yourself in coconut oil and wrap
yourself with plastic is that that
sounds ridiculous when you say it yes
like but when a woman say it it makes
sense you know it's like a moisturizing
thing that is natural so it doesn't have
chemicals yes and it's very good for you
you can put it in your hair in your face
in your eyelashes in every
it goes everywhere
Sophia Vergara has anyone checked for a
penis
[Applause]
for sure bigger than yours
[Applause]